[Música]
é brincar é coisa séria
em novembro de 2015 minha sobrinha e
afilhada mariah viu o episódio de
racismo na escola em que estudava
na ocasião as meninas se reuniram para
eleger a menina mais preta da turma a
mariah a única menina negra foi a eleita
o fato foi tratado pela escola e pelos
familiares das crianças como brincadeira
as crianças pediram desculpas mas a dor
ficou e é importante falar do
contribuinte impactado ela ficou assim
como a minha família também ficou a
gente quer acreditar que o racismo está
chegando ao fim
aí acontece uma coisa como essa ea gente
percebe que não
diante da tristeza da mariah eu tive a
idéia de fazer a primeira boneca de pano
negra uma tentativa de reafirmar a sua
beleza e o valor que ela tem pra mim
daí surgiu amarais boneca de pano um
projeto voltado principalmente ao
público infantil mas que tem encantado
adultos de todas as idades
pergunto a vocês quem aqui tem mais de
30 anos
vocês sabiam que um estudo realizado
pela ong avante que promove a campanha
cadê a nossa boneca no brasil revelou
que de 762 modelos de bonecas oferecidas
nos sites dos fabricantes apenas 50 e
pressão negras e que apenas 7% das
bonecas vendidas nas lojas online são
negras no nosso cotidiano com a vida
corrida
se a gente vai numa loja e não encontra
boneca que a gente quer a gente acaba
levando outra coisa
panelinha bichinho de pelúcia carrinhos
a gente finge que não vê fingir que não
sente mas a verdade é que a gente sente
sentimos que os heróis e heroínas não
nos representa
então e os princípios e as princesas
também não e que até as poucas bonecas
negras na verdade são bonecas brancas
pintadas de marrom não possui as nossas
características faciais
nem sequer o nosso cabelo somos muitos
somos 54.921 cento da população
brasileira segundo o ibge é de 2016 mas
não somos representados
e não é só no universo dos brinquedos na
literatura infantil não é diferente
mesmo em grandes livrarias nós temos
dificuldade de encontrar livros com
personagens negros e negras livros que
abordam os hábitos ea cultura de uma
parcela tão importante da população nos
programas infantis
também são poucos os personagens negros
e negras
eu lembro que quando eu era criança
minha brincadeira favorita era enfiar
para o dia que eu fosse selecionada
pessoalmente é claro pela xuxa para ser
paquita
eu não fazia ideia que as minhas
características étnicas pudessem me
afastar tanto do meu sonho do el
descobrir ainda tão pequena que eu não
pertence alguns espaços
durante muito tempo eu não sentir não me
sentia autorizada a frequentar espaços
de representatividade mas eu não falo
isso com pesar
minha infância adolescência servirão
para que eu me tornasse a mulher atento
observador é que eu sou hoje
minha experiência de vida associado à
graduação em psicologia faz com que eu
tenha sensibilidade para perceber a
função importante do brinquedo e das
brincadeiras na formação do do sujeito
humano da criança e o quanto ela
favorece uma boa relação com a
autoestima porque a criança se sente
identificada com um brinquedo que lhe é
agradável
nada é mais devastador ao
desenvolvimento psicossocial de uma
criança do que a experiência de não
pertencer
não ter valor
vocês sabiam como as crianças bem a fada
do dente vocês imaginam como as crianças
vêem a fada do dente
pois então eu perguntei para as crianças
de uma escola na lomba do pinheiro umas
minha fada do dente
as respostas foram unânimes loira
cabelos compridos magra
então eu mostrei pra elas a minha fada
do dente
a fada do dente é um ser mágico cheia de
simbolismo e ela pode ter a cor que a
criança quiser
a criança só precisa tem a possibilidade
de conhecer outras fada do dente
eu penso que a criança que se sente
representada no seu brinquedo se sente
pertencente à sociedade que vive através
da sua auto imagem
deixa eu contar pra vocês esses dias eu
voltava da padaria e encontrei uma
menina
aproximadamente uns três anos eu percebi
que ela me olhava com uma atenção
carinho eu fiquei olhando pra ela ela
olhou pra mim ficou sorrindo pra mim eu
sorri de volta e ela já estava uma
mochila produtora brinquedos naquele
momento eu senti que eu fazia parte
daquele universo conhecido por ela
eu pensei que seria meu apoio brinquedos
essa cena foi muito importante para mim
porque pela primeira vez eu senti que eu
representava uma criança o mesmo q as
paquitas representaram pra mim ainda me
surpreendo quando eu conheço as crianças
e os seus desejos de representação
eu conheci uma menina não e vocês vão se
perguntar mas o que é se sentir
representado enquanto brinca
e eu respondo é uma menina negra que se
sente representada pelo ariel todos
conhecem ariel área é uma sereia não tem
pernas mas deixa eu contar pra vocês
essa menina ela tem uma deficiência
física e mental e é uma cadeirante
então o personagem que ela identifica
também não usa as pernas
é um menino autista inserido numa escola
regular que o personagem que ele se
identifica é o kiko se lembram do kikolo
chaves o kiko é menos dependente frágil
e às vezes até agredido pelas outras
crianças
ainda sobre representação eu conto pra
vocês sobre dois meninos que eu conheci
dois meninos de uma mesma faixa etária
crianças que não se conhecem e que se
sentem representados pelo banco
vocês conhecem o goku boca um personagem
asiático um dos muitos personagens que
eu transformei negro
à medida que o gol fica mais forte
o cabelo dele cresce e muda de cor
esses meninos então um de cabelo azul e
um de cabelo vermelho amarelo
o personagem diz o personagem que eles
mais se representam é o goku um deles
jair ainda disse
meu herói favorito agora da minha cor
isso é representação outro fato também
que eu gosto de cultura que eu quero
trazer pra vocês é de uma adolescente
branca que me trouxe um relato na escola
em que estudava
haviam duas bonecas na sexta feira
cada uma a cada uma das crianças devia
levar uma boneca para casa cuidar lá e
devolveu na segunda atividade simples na
ela seria uma das últimas a levar a
boneca porque o seu nome era uma das
últimas letras do alfabeto
mas acabou sendo uma das primeiras
porque ninguém quis levar a boneca negra
e ela conta que a família manifestou
estranhamento quando ela chegou em casa
com aquela boneca negra mas pra ela ama
tudo bem eu vá tudo certo
você apenas de uma boneca só isso é só
isso
quando eu descobri que as bonecas
são uma espécie de portal entre o adulto
que narra ea criança de outrora
eu descobri que a gente pode escrever
uma nova história é impressionante como
a vida ressignifica as nossas dores faz
delas inspiração inspiração para desejar
novos sonhos
atualmente eu ministra uma oficina de
bonecas do grupo d para grupos de 20 e
30 pessoas são mulheres de todas as
idades filhas mães avós metas unidas
pelo resgate ancestralidade umas
mulheres faziam os porões dos navios
as mulheres rasgavam tiras das suas
saias davam nós e construíram bonecas
pra acalentar suas crianças
nessa última oficina que ministrei agora
em junho
a menina chamada manu disse que a boneca
que ela havia confeccionado e
customizado como o seu gosto pessoal se
chamaria lille
chorei de emoção representação maior do
que essa
não há e é isso sabe é isso que eu
acredito que é preciso que a gente saia
desse lugar comum que a gente repense e
que a gente faça algo real para mudar o
que nos incomoda o que nos afeta e o que
machuca as pessoas que a gente ama muito
obrigado